>> All right. Thank
you very much.
This is the second
afternoon panel.
We'll be hearing about fairness,
and this is going
to be moderated by
our very own Hanna Wallach
from our sister lab and that's
New York. So, take it up.
>> Great. Okay. So, now
that Nicole has told
you all to sit down,
I want you all to stand back up.
Great. Okay. Now I want you
to either stamp your feet,
jump up and down or stretch.
Okay. Perfect. Now you can
sit back down. All right.
So, I want this to be
an interactive panel and I
want people to ask questions,
and so I wanted to make sure
you're all paying attention.
Good. All right.
So, as Nicole said, I'm Hanna.
For those of you
who don't know me,
I'm a principal researcher in
Microsoft Research New York and
an adjunct professor
at UMass Amherst.
My background is in
Machine Learning,
and specifically I study
Machine Learning and society.
So, I both use Machine Learning
to study society,
and I study the effect that
Machine Learning has on society,
as Machine Learning
and AI are becoming
much more common and widespread.
Over the past few years,
I've been concentrating
specifically
on issues of fairness,
accountability,
transparency and ethics as
they relate to AI and
Machine Learning.
Indeed, that is the topic
of today's panel, unsurprisingly.
I think it's a really
important and timely topic.
So, I'm really glad
that we're having
this panel discussion
on this here today.
So, at this point,
it's pretty clear that we're kind
of living in the age of AI.
Machine Learning is everywhere
and at least for the moment,
it looks like it's here to
stay and this is great.
This is great for
researchers like me.
companies like Microsoft.
But at the same time,
we're also seeing that
these kinds of
opportunities also raise
new challenges and challenges
that have received
a lot of attention in
the media recently.
I've really highlighted
how important it
is that we get AI right,
that we don't let
AI discriminate or
disadvantage previously
disadvantaged groups.
So, how many of you have
seen one of these stories?
Great, so pretty much everyone.
That's what I was hoping for.
Good. So, then you'll
know that this is
a really complicated
and fraught landscape
with a lot of different
key stakeholders,
ranging from yeah
sure researchers but
companies like Microsoft,
the government,
civil rights and
civil liberties organizations,
and of course the people who
use these technologies and
who are affected by these
technologies in their lives.
So, we haven't really
accomplished group of panelists
here today: Timnit Gebru,,
Debbie Hellman,
Adam Kalai and Mira Lane
and they're going to
explore this landscape
here today and in turn,
I hope that you'll walk away from
this panel with
a deeper understanding
of why these issues are so
important, why
they're non-trivial,
why they really get at
the core of the relationship
between technology
and society and
why it's important that we
take them really seriously
even when there are
no obvious right answers.
So, here's how this
is going to go.
I am going to start by briefly
introducing the panelists,
and then I'm going to
ask each panelist to
talk for a few minutes
about themselves,
their own work and how they
work relates to the
topics of fairness,
accountability,
transparency and ethics.
Then what I'm gonna
do is I'm going
to ask them a series of
questions to get
the discussion going,
and after that, I'm going
to hand the floor over to
you and this is really
your opportunity.
I'm sure many of you
have questions about
these topics that you really
want to know the answers to.
This is your opportunity
to ask them.
Okay. If at anytime you
want to ask a question,
either while the panelists
are talking about
their own work or while
I'm asking questions,
you should feel free to do so.
Just raise your hand
and I will wave at
Nicole and she will
run a mic over to you.
Okay. Wonderful.
Great. So, with that,
I'm going to introduce
our panelists.
Okay. So Timnit Gebru just
finished her post-doc in
the faith group at
Microsoft Research, New York
and we miss her a lot.
She is now a research
scientist in
the ethical AI team at
Google AI and she's
currently studying
the ethical
considerations underlying
any data mining project
and methods of auditing
and mitigating
bias in socio-technical systems.
As a co-founder of
the group Black in AI,
she works to
both increase diversity
in the field and to reduce
the negative impacts
of racial bias in
training data used for
human-centric
machine-learning models.
Great. So, Debbie
Hellman is a D. Lurton
Massee Professor of Law in
the University of Virginia,
School of Law.
Her work focuses
on discrimination,
both from a philosophical
and a legal perspective.
She's particularly
interested in the questions,
what is discrimination
and what makes it wrong?
In fact, she wrote a book called
When is Discrimination Wrong in
2008 and has continued to work
on these topics in
the years since.
She's also new to
AI and therefore
wants you to know
that you shouldn't
ask her anything super technical.
Okay. Adam. Adam Kalai
is a very serious
principal researcher
in Microsoft Research,
New England, although
he is better
known as the husband
of Yael Kalai.
Adam has had over
50 papers rejected,
counting multiple
submissions, multiple
times in top
computer science venues,
only the best for Adam.
The last time I moderated
a panel that Adam was on,
he made a fool of me.
I'm going to get my revenge,
but I've decided that I won't
tell him when this
is going to happen.
It may be in today's panel,
it may be in the next panel
that I moderate that he's on.
We will see.
Our final panelist is Mira Lane,
who is the partner
director of ethics and
society within Cloud
and AI at Microsoft.
She has a background in art,
computer science and
mathematics and she holds
numerous patents across
platforms and
collaborative interfaces.
Mira's team is
responsible for guiding
technical and experience
innovation towards ethical,
responsible and
sustainable outcomes.
So, please join me in
welcoming our panelists.
>> Okay. So now we're going
to have the panelists each talk
a little bit about their work
and how it relates to fairness,
accountability,
transparency, and ethics.
I think maybe what we'll do since
I started with Timney before,
I will start with Mary this time.
>> Okay. So, as
Hannah was saying,
I'm part of the Engineering
team at Microsoft.
I'm not part of
Microsoft Research.
But what you've heard over
and over again and
all of the panels,
is a need for a bridge between
research and what's happening
on the applied side.
So, my team acts as a bridge.
What we do, is we take ideas
and policies that are happening
in research and across
Microsoft and then we
look at those and say,
"How do we bring these into
an engineering
context and how do we
apply these so that
thousands of engineers,
designers, product thinkers,
sales folks can then
do responsible things
with technology."
This involves everything from
looking at how we collect data,
how we do scenario planning,
how we look at impacts and
consequences of our work,
how we actually develop and where
we set benchmarks in our code,
and then how we maintain
our systems once they've
gone out the door.
So, this is a new type
of model in the company.
I don't think anything
like this quite exists,
and so, it's an experiment.
We're innovating and
we're trying new things,
but it's a fairly big investment.
There's about 20 people
working on this.
It's a multidisciplinary group.
There are social
psychologists on the team,
there are developers, designers,
storytellers,
creative coders and, so,
we're playing around
with this space and
we're trying to bring
responsible thinking
and responsible innovation into
a complex and gnarly space,
where we look at
speech technologies,
facial recognition, we do
things around virtual
reality and HoloLens.
So, a lot of
the gnarly things that
you tend to see in the news,
are in this group
that I'm working on.
>> Thank you.
>> You are welcome.
>> All right. Adam.
>> I am a Machine Learning
AI Researcher
and you can think of me as
the naive user of AI
Machine Learning that would have
naturally made algorithms
that discriminate except,
that I'm in this lab surrounded
by people like this and
many other people in our lab and
then they made us
think before, Oh gee!
Maybe we should think
a little bit about what
these technologies will
do and then we started
doing that and then covering
various vices that
we sourced in words,
that you might see gender bias or
racial biases and what effects
that they will have on
various algorithms we design.
So, we are also
thinking about how we
might deal with that.
>> Great. Thank you Adam. Okay.
>> Okay, I hope I'm
not going to talk for
too long because
those were shorter.
But I thought I'd tell you about
a paper I'm working
on now just because I
always think it's interesting
to hear what people are
working on and because
it's a great resource.
It's a little bit selfish,
a great resource for me.
In case you guys have some input,
I would love to hear
it because as I said,
I'm a bit of an interloper here.
So I'm working on a paper
that has to do with
the controversy about the
COMPAS Risk Assessment Tool,
which I imagine most of
you are familiar with.
I see most heads nodding
but just briefly,
it's a risk
assessment tool that's
used to determine who should
get out of prison early,
on parole, it's also
used in bail settings
in many many states
around the country.
And there was a big brouhaha
after an expose by ProPublica,
which alleged that the tool
discriminated between blacks and
whites and didn't
treat them fairly.
The response from the company
that makes COMPAS
which is Northpointe,
was to say, "That's not true,
the tool does treat blacks
and whites fairly or doesn't
discriminate between
blacks and whites,"
and the up short of
that debate was that,
they were focusing on
different measures.
That, Northpointe was focusing on
one measure for assessing
whether blacks and
whites are treated equally and
ProPublica and
the critics of COMPAS
were focusing on another measure.
That led to then a
series of papers by
people like you all
that showed that,
in many many contexts,
in fact in most contexts,
it would be impossible to
equalize with regard
to both measures.
That is, you couldn't
treat blacks and
whites equally with
regard to the measure
that Northpointe was focusing
on and at the same time
with regard to the measure
that ProPublica was focusing on.
Thus leading to the question,
which one should
we prefer and why?
In a second series of
papers that looked
at that question,
that second generation
question was posed as,
which measure of fairness
should we prefer and why?
Where I want to
intercede in this debate
is to say that there's something
wrong with that framing,
that they're not both
measures of fairness,
and so, we're not comparing
two things in the same domain.
That one of the measures
is a measure of
fairness and the other measure
maybe has some implications for
fairness but isn't itself
a measure of fairness.
So just if I can say
a few more words,
the two measures, the one that
Northpointe was focusing on was,
if two people get a risk score
of let's say eight out of 10,
that a black person and
a white person who
both get a score of
eight are equally
likely to recidivate.
That is, eight out of
10 people who get that score,
will in fact recidivate.
So the score was equally
predictive for both groups.
So it was an equal
predictive accuracy.
That was true for
for the COMPAS tool.
The measure that
ProPublica was focused on,
was not asking if
you got a score,
what was the likelihood
that you would recidivate,
was probably asking the question
in a different kind
of way was saying,
"If you are someone who was
at low risk for recidivating,
what's the likelihood
that the tool would
accurately characterize
you as low risk?"
There, there was
a big difference between
how a low-risk black and
a low-risk white person were
characterized by the tool.
A low-risk black person
was much more likely to be
mis-characterized by the tool
than a low-risk white person.
So, another way of
characterizing this
would be to say that,
the scores were equally accurate,
they had equal predictive
accuracy but of course they
weren't perfect and when
there were mistakes,
the mistakes went in
different directions.
One had more false positives and
the other more more
false negatives.
So then the question is,
which measure do we care about,
equal predictive accuracy or
equalizing the error rates?
The false positives and
false negative rates.
What I'm arguing in this paper,
which I'm happy to talk to
you more about in the Q
and A or in coffee, is that,
the measure that looked at
equalizing the error rates,
is a measure of fairness
because it's looking at,
what's the burden of mistakes.
How are, is, are the burdens of
mistakes falling equally
on the two groups?
So it relates to the way
in which we treat people.
Whereas equal
predictive accuracy is
about what we believe
about people.
That is, it's about
belief versus action.
That is, if the scores don't
have equal predictive accuracy,
a score of eight will mean
something different
for a black person
versus a white person if we give
up on predictive accuracy.
Therefore, I won't
know what to believe
about a person who
has a score of eight,
I won't know what to believe
about what that means,
about the likelihood that
he or she will recidivate.
But a score that
relates to what I ought
to believe versus
what I ought to do,
is not related to fairness
in any straightforward way.
That's the basic conceptual
point of the paper is that,
predictive accuracy
relates to belief,
error rate balance
relates to action,
and therefore it's more naturally
a fairness space concern.
>> I'm glad you brought
up the compass dataset
because I studied
Computer Vision,
and the only interests I
had was in studying
Computer Vision.
But towards the end of my PhD,
I read that ProPublica article
and I was terrified.
So, that's how I
started to get more
interested in these questions
of issues and fairness.
So, my PhD was in using
Computer Vision to do
visual data mining.
So, for example, using images
to predict things about
the society and that
naturally has certain biases,
the kinds of biases
that we might discuss.
So, that's when I
realized even my own work
suffers from these
issues of fairness.
So, I then met Joy Bolognini,
who is advisee of
Ethan who was moderating
the prior panel and
we worked on a paper
showing that there are
disparities in the commercial
face recognition systems,
and how accurate they
are for different
subgroups of people.
So, we looked at skin types.
We used a dermatology
classification system
for skin tone and gender.
In addition to my work in
Computer Vision and this work,
I view what's for me equally
important is to make
sure that the voices
of the people who are
unfairly affected by these
systems are amplified.
So, for example, because
diversity gives you
domain knowledge.
So, Joy Bolongini, she's
a much darker skinned
Black woman and
so the reason that
she came up with
this idea of using
Fitzpatrick skin type
rather than race,
which a lot of people had
done this kind of announces with
race is because of
her domain knowledge
about colors and about
a whole bunch of other things.
So, I think, equally
important is to
make sure that the people who
bring this domain knowledge,
that their voices are amplified.
>> Great. Thanks everyone.
Okay. So, I'm going to start with
some questions and
the first question which I
want to ask really is
a overview question and
stage setting question is,
what are the different
ways that one
might think about
whether a decision or
output obtained via
an AI based system
treats people fairly or not?
I'm going to kick that question
over to you Debbie
because of your background
in discrimination.
>> So, the first point I
would emphasize
about that is that
there are different
ways of answering
that question and people
disagree about that,
and so that's what's
interesting, anyway about it.
So, obviously, one way
that people think about
what fairness is,
is the idea of
treating like cases
alike and I think many people
strive for that idea.
I don't think that's
the only way of
thinking about it and I
think we make a mistake if
we emphasize that too much,
but that is obviously one way of
thinking about what fairness is,
is treating like cases alike.
Another way would be treating
everybody literally the same.
That's not that plausible in
most situations but another idea.
A third way is one that
you mentioned before,
which is making sure not to
disadvantage already
disadvantaged groups.
A fourth way, which is,
we see dominant in
legal discourse is just
avoiding the use of certain
traits or classifications.
That's another conception.
Then a fifth one might be
not doing things that are
demeaning in some way and that
is not an exhaustive list,
but just gives you
a flavor of possibilities.
>> Do any of the rest of you
have anything to add to that?
>> Well, I think
one of the things
to add to that is if
we look back into,
again the engineering system,
having a robust set of
test cases that we can
then go and apply against
the systems to say
what kinds of discrimination
might be happening in
the system, is very important.
Because one of
the things we don't do
right now is actually separate
out those subgroups and
the categories of people that
might be using a system.
It's something that
we're trying to
build into the new way that we
design advanced technologies
and look at: Well,
we know that the system is
going to impact these classes
of people and we know that some
of these are
vulnerable audiences,
and how do we proactively go and
investigate the system
to see how they're
performing against
certain subgroups?
And then, go in and set
benchmarks and say, okay,
your code cannot go out
the door if it doesn't meet
a certain criteria across
all of these different subgroups.
There's a lot of work
that we need to do
to even get there but that's how
I would take what you're
saying and translate it
into getting the system
to perform a certain way.
Because the thing that
I worry about the most,
is that we end up
talking about it a lot,
but then we don't go and
change the system in
such a way that it
performs in a way that is
fair or it puts fairness
into the system
and I don't think
enough work is happening
in that space right now.
Which is why it's so important
to me to go in and be
that bridge between
all the great work that you guys
are doing and then the engineers,
who are not necessarily
thinking about
this problem space in
the same way that this group is.
>> Can I just? Go.
>> For data sheets,
for data sets that
paper that we wrote.
>> Yes.
>> Another one I
just score called
model cards from
model performance,
which is trying to basically say,
if you're going to, let's say,
let's take a
face recognition system.
Before you have a pre-trained
model or an API available,
how about you tell us some of
the tests that you've done,
some of the false positive rates
or false negative rates,
or we have a whole host of tests,
but I'm just making a plan.
>> You were going to respond.
>> What I was going to
say for data sheets,
we've actually been
spending a lot of time.
So, I'll give you
the high-level view
and then maybe
Hannah you can come in and say,
"Mira there's a more robust way
to talk about it."
But when I talk about
data sheets to our engineers,
I say, "These are basically
nutrition labels for datasets."
So, when you look at a dataset,
you understand the composition
of it, what's inside it?
How it was collected?
How can you use the data?
So, that if you're
going and using
this data in another model
that you might be training,
you have a sense for what
that data can be used for and
how that data's performing
against other things. Yeah.
>> Tim, that you should.
>> Yeah. So, there's two parts.
So, data sheets is for it
for datasets and I think,
it would be helpful
for even when people
are sharing datasets internally.
Because a lot of time
somebody collects a dataset,
uses it for one purpose
and another team gets
that data to try to use it
for another purpose and then
some information is lost
when you transfer it.
You don't know what the
original reason what the data
that was collected for,
you don't know what
the legal considerations are,
the intended use cases
are, et cetera.
So, we talk about
fairness accountability
and transparency.
I think this is low hanging
fruit in transparency.
I think there's
a lot we can do in
transparency that
we're not doing.
So, another follow-up paper that
I just mentioned is
a similar thing for models.
Because when we were initially
writing data sheets,
we were thinking
about datasets and
models but it turned
out that it's actually
very complicated to even just
do this idea for datasets,
but then there's
a second part to it,
which is when you're releasing
a model or an API like
I've just talked about
a paper we wrote with Joy,
where we were auditing
commercial gender
classification systems.
What kind of information
are you giving the user?
Are you giving them
intended use cases?
Are you giving them disclaimers?
Like don't use this to
decide whether someone
is a criminal or not.
So, that's the follow-up
in terms of models.
>> So, I just wanted
to push back on
one thing that you said
if that's okay Mira.
>> Of course.
>> The idea that
you're going to audit,
I don't know what word to
use but something like that,
the systems, you still need to
say what you're
auditing them for.
So, if you're auditing them
for the idea of treating
like cases alike
versus auditing them
for the idea of
disadvantaging previously
disadvantaged groups,
those are often going to
yield very different answers.
So, it doesn't have
to audit them for
fairness but to the extent
that we have different views
about what that is,
that's going to yield
very different projects.
>> There's one more fairness
that you didn't mention
which is very widely,
very common one,
which is just that if your system
was trained with
any kind of data,
then it's objective
and it's fair.
>> With any kind of data?
>> I don't believe it,
but I think in some ways,
the datasheets work speaks to
that and it says
to people, "Well,
think about what data
you used," but it is
a belief that a lot of
people have and that's
one that we need to dispel,
but many people find
that intuitive or that's
their first reaction,
"Oh this came with data.
Therefore, it's probably fair."
Justifying things with data is
a standard way to justify
making decisions,
which isn't always
fair obviously.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I'm interested
in digging a little bit
further into this idea of how
each of you thinks
about fairness or
even measures fairness when
it comes to AI based systems.
As you said Debbie,
there's a whole bunch
of different kinds of
metrics or measures
that you can look at,
there are various different
trade-offs between
them and some types of unfairness
might be just inherently
very difficult
to quantify or to automate.
So, I'm interested from
all of you to learn a
little bit more about
which approaches,
which measures, which
metrics do you use?
How do you think about
testing for fairness?
>> Actually, this
was a question I
wanted to ask Debbie, too.
So, the way I think about it
is I don't have anything to
add to the metrics
that you mentioned.
I think it's context specific
too, like which one,
which metric to use for
what purpose and so
when we're talking
about auditing systems,
the way I think about
it is how to just
audit it for a whole bunch
of different metrics
that people have come
up with and then
maybe when you know the context,
sometimes maybe having
false positives is
worse than something else.
So, maybe then the person who's
using the system can make
a decision about if this system
is appropriate or not.
What do you think about laden?
What is your opinion on
this type of approach?
Do you think we
should have just one
or two metrics that we all agree
on and so from there or?
>> I agree with you that
different contexts call
for different things.
That if I'm trying to
decide whether to
put someone in jail.
The standard for being
certain that that person,
or keeping someone in
jail really is guilty,
is very different
than if I'm trying to
decide whether to
give someone a job.
An issue that we saw addressed in
the Kavanaugh hearing
quite recently.
The standard for putting
someone on the Supreme Court
versus putting someone behind
bars should be, I
think, different.
So, the cost of the false
positives versus false
negative about that
surely are different.
So, I agree with
the idea that context makes
different things salient.
The cost of false positives
versus false negatives in
different contexts make
a huge difference.
For sure, I agree with that.
But the idea that
we'll throw all our fairness
measures out there.
If it passes all of them,
it's great and if it
fails all of them,
it's probably bad.
If it passes some
and fails some, it's
somewhere in between.
That's appealing. We were
talking about this last night.
But I have a worry that
all the interesting cases,
the ones that really
puzzle us are going
to be in those in-between cases.
So, maybe it's not going to be
that helpful, and that really,
I think the issues are posed
because given injustice
in society over time,
race, sex, and other
protected characteristics
are going to track with
a lot of qualities or traits
that people legitimately
care about.
So, there's a deep
moral issue about how
disruptive you want to be
of those correlations.
That's a moral question or
a normative question
that we have to address.
>> Nicole, do you
have a question?
>> Hi, guys. Thanks.
Very interesting commentary.
I was curious, a lot
of the discussion of
fairness so far has been
about the fairness of
the outcome and I'm wondering if
there's two different processes
that lead to that same outcome.
Is there distinguishing one
is fair and one is not and we
should prefer one
process to another,
or is it just about the outcome?
>> I think it depends.
I have trouble keeping it in
the abstract for some of these
because the context in
the scenario is so important,
so tied to how you
would even measure it.
So, I guess the answer is it
depends on what the scenario is.
I don't know, maybe we can
run through some cases-
>> I think that those are
different- that process
often matters to fairness.
In fact, it shows us
why sometimes we
don't care about say,
treating light cases
alike in a certain sense.
That is the
quintessential example
of a fair procedure is,
let's flip the coin,
let's draw straws.
Is a lottery-type system.
That's not actually trying
to track anything about,
"I'm really choosing the people
who have the skills for the job."
It's just modeling
fairness as procedure.
So, sometimes we care
about fair procedures.
Sometimes we care about
getting the correct results
where those are
independently determined
and sometimes
we care about a little bit
of each, I think.
>> So Mira, I'm interested
in how your team
actually measures fairness and
actually tests the systems
that you're building.
>> Yeah. So, I'll
give an example and
I'll make it- I won't
give the exact example.
But let's say we were
looking at a system that
decides who should come into
this room and who should not.
One of the things that
we do is we work with
the team who's making
this design, that algorithm.
Before we even start
collecting any data,
we started running through
the scenarios for how we
might operate around this system.
So, we identify different
groups of people.
We call that subgroup
classification.
So, we're identifying
these different categories
of people that might
end up using it.
You might have children
coming in and out on
the weekend with their families.
You might have people
with head coverings.
You might have
people coming in on
a rainy day and how it changes
the environmental factors.
So, we start going through all of
the scenarios and we create
a set of stakeholders.
We create a set of scenarios.
Then, we use that to
decide how we're going
to collect data.
So, we use that to inform
our data collection effort.
At the same time that
we're collecting data,
we start citing, "Hey,
how do we set benchmarks for
the outcomes of these subgroups?
What kind of false positives
do we want to have,
what kind of error rates
do we want to have?"
We start coming up with
a model around that.
Then, as we start
designing our algorithms,
one of the things
we're trying to do is,
we've got a whole
platform we use,
and we call it our
Dev Inner-loop.
So, it's a place that developers
go and put their
models in and they
test it against
test data that they
might have just collected
with themselves,
they might have- they
might test it against
ground truth data that
we've collected explicitly.
Then, trying to put benchmarks
in place in that platform,
that can take
our estimates around
error and false positives
and say, "Okay.
How are we performing now against
this very tagged dataset that we
used during our scenario
identification?"
So, it's something
we're testing out.
We haven't finished going
through that entire system yet.
But I think that
this is something
that the team hasn't
thought of before.
I'll give you an example,
we had a piece of
hardware technology that we were
using to detect irises
and gaze tracking.
After a while, we realized
that there was a category of
people that it just didn't work
for and we weren't
really sure why.
We thought we had collected
tens of thousands of eyeballs.
We thought we had enough.
Quantity was more important at
the time instead of quality.
We realized that green eyeballs
just perform differently
in the system.
We didn't have enough of them and
they were actually hard
for us to collect.
So, some of the things we
discover after the fact.
We discover them through
anomalies or bugs.
Then, it requires us to be really
thoughtful about
understanding why
that happened because we may not
even- it's easy to think
about race and gender,
and those explicit qualities.
But then, there are
things that you
don't typically think about.
I wouldn't expect
blue and green eyeballs
to perform differently as we're
tracking where they're looking.
That was done a while ago.
But you can imagine looking
at the system and
how it's performing.
Where you see bugs and anomalies,
we have to go and dig
deeper into that and do
a little bit more work on it.
>> Great. So, you
mentioned in your answer
a couple of different
application areas there.
So, seeing who should be
let into a room or not,
maybe tracking somebody's eyes
for some purpose.
Then, there's a bunch
of other areas
that you can think of where
Machine Learning is either
currently used or could be used.
I'm interested in getting
some perspectives from
the panelists about what you
think are the most
important areas in which
tech companies will
face fairness issues.
>> I can start with a couple.
One is, sorry.
One is, there's a whole-
employment is one example.
So, there was a whole panel
about LinkedIn before.
So, LinkedIn is a platform where
it directly gives you
access to jobs, let's say.
But there's roundabout
ways in which you
can also face these issues.
So, for example, there's
a company called
HireVue that records
people on camera.
Then, does a motion
recognition on them.
Then, gives that information
to the people who
are interviewing,
the interviewers.
So, the people who are providing,
like Affectiva is providing
emotion recognition technology
to this company.
I don't know how that would
work if it was found that
they were discriminating-
By certain attributes,
and then that was due
to that technology,
the emotion
recognition technology
or other things that
they were using
from this third-party company.
I think you can
face these kinds of
things in a roundabout
manner too,
even if you're providing
face recognition technology or
some other thing
that then is used by
some third-party entity to
make decisions about
people's lives.
>> I would agree that hiring
is a great example of
a domain where you want to
be fair, especially because,
for what Tim had said before,
that if you have
a diverse group of people,
you can make sure your
products are fairer as well.
So, there's kind of
a compounding effect there.
If your products
are not working in
certain neighborhoods or for
certain groups of people,
you're more likely to notice that
if you have a diverse workforce.
So, they can figure
out hiring algorithms
with the help of that.
>> We have a question over here.
>> Yeah, I do. I
guess in large part,
it's probably for Deborah,
but I'm not sure.
So, one thing that
came out, especially,
say obligations like hiring,
and actually from your
story when I started
raising my hand,
that one way to figure out
fairness is to test
for these groups.
Test if the face
recognition works just
as well for very dark faces
than for light faces
or some other.
But there is aspiration
of fairness.
They're protected, legally
protected attributes
that we may not
discriminate based on sex,
and race, and whatnot.
I guess this is
data-driven world.
I think it's a very natural idea
that the only way we can refer.
If we actually use
the protective attribute in
our decision-making for
the obvious reason,
because the protected
attribute is so
correlated with a lot
of other stuff,
that not using it doesn't
allow us to even test for
things you're testing for.
But that raises a legal question
and maybe all of you,
but you're the lawyers,
so that's maybe you.
Will the legal community
accept this?
That in order to be fair
to the protected groups,
the systems actually have to
use the protected attribute,
that's the way to make it fair,
rather than the idea that
we are fair to women if we
don't use sex as an attribute.
>> Right. So, the legal
system unfortunately,
perhaps has glams onto
our focuses onto
whether you use race,
sex, or some other
protected classifications
as a classification.
But you have to separate
two different ways
that you might use it,
so that I'm extrapolating,
I think from what
you said, you tell
me if I had gotten it right.
So, suppose you have an algorithm
that doesn't use race or sex,
but after it pops out
a bunch of things,
you check to see
whether there are
very few women in the pool,
or very few racial
minorities in the pool.
So, you're looking
at the results in
terms of the racial
classifications produced,
and then thinking, well,
that's too much of
a disparate impact on women
or racial minorities,
so let's revisit the stuff
that goes into the algorithm.
That I think it's
perfectly permissible.
I think in the literature,
there's been this worry that
the court's decision
and reaching somehow,
which I can talk about
later or whatever,
somehow doesn't allow that.
I think that's
a dramatic overreading,
which I think that's
perfectly permissible.
But if one of the traits
that's actually
in your algorithm is race or sex,
I think you will get
into legal trouble,
and I think what you point
out about that is that's
an unfortunate fact
of the way that
currently our legal system
understands what's prohibited.
It's not something that's
easy to fix because it's
the court's interpretation
of constitutional law.
So, let me say that it's
somewhat easy to fix if you're
talking about employers,
but not if you're talking
about the government.
So, the constitution only
affects governmental actors,
but there are a lot of
governmental actors.
>> I just want to jump in here.
I recognize that
I'm not a panelist,
so I will keep this very brief.
I did write a paper on
exactly this topic,
this summer with a lawyer,
where we looked at
really the lower and specifically
disparate treatment,
and thought about ways
in which it might
be okay to use those attributes.
One of the scenarios
that we looked
at was the case
where those kinds of
individual level sensitive
attributes are used during
the training process to
develop your classifier,
but then at deployment time,
it has no such access
to those attributes.
We argue that that is fine
from a disparate
treatment perspective.
The paper is not
currently online,
but probably will be online
within the next few weeks.
I will email you,
and let you know when it is.
>> Can I ask a very
quick question? Sorry.
>> Thank you. I guess it
just is a follow-up comment.
I thought that this
would during the break.
Before the discrimination cases
for college admission,
Cornell Engineering used to have
weighing differently
the SAT scores
for women than for men,
and the argument they made,
which I actually
support as an argument,
that SAT course on its own and
not something we care about.
We care about them as a predictor
of college performance,
and they had data to show
that the lower SAT
course for women,
same as SAT scores for
women predicts higher GPA.
Therefore, they can weigh
up the GPAs for women.
They no longer do it because
I guess it's not legal,
but it's kind of said,
they had a point.
>> Yeah. So, I have
a much more general question,
which is that we are
very focused on US law,
and we have companies that
are operating globally.
We have Machine
Learning conferences
that are international,
researchers that
are international,
and this area of fairness is
intertwined with legal systems.
I mean, I don't know.
Our algorithms that
were coming up with,
the scenarios we're
coming up with are
very intertwined with US law,
and I don't know how to
address that. What do we do?
Do you have different
researchers in different places,
and addressing it based
on different legalities.
Should we have
one more international law
or something like this because-
>> This comes up in
privacy as well,
especially with the GDPR
at the movement,
which is specifically Europe.
But yet, we look at
companies like Microsoft,
that are international companies,
and suddenly, that is
applied everywhere,
not just within Europe.
So, I think there's
perhaps stuff we can
learn from some of
these other disciplines as well.
>> I think it also ties into
the first panel on
long-term thinking,
where maybe we should think
about what is ethical or
fair in a philosophical way
also as researchers,
and then maybe overtime laws
will change or
catch up with that.
>> That's also
a very Western-centric view,
and one of the things we debate,
ad nauseam in our group,
is are we pushing too much of
a Western-centric
viewpoints because
we are an international
corporation.
When you talk about privacy,
and you look at other cultures,
large parts of
the world view privacy
and fairness quite
differently than you
do in the Western side
of the world.
It's not something we have
resolved anything yet,
but it is a constant source
of tension and debate
because there are
such different viewpoints on it.
Certain cultures don't emphasize
individuals in the same way
versus collective,
and so trying to
navigate that is
a massive challenge for us.
>> Question over there?
>> There's a kind of
[inaudible] reinforce that.
Sometimes show
things that occur in
one jurisdiction
become best practice,
and a lot of a number of
jurisdictions adopt them,
build on that side of
the GDPR, Denmark.
They came out of Europe,
America [inaudible] today.
So, if you have
lived in the West,
we're [inaudible] There are
other areas where governments
willing to accept that,
the rights of US government
to access data,
all things that make
your main governments in
particular want data
kept in Europe,
but like I said, it's
kind of protections.
So, there is a very old
question of what does
internationalization mean with
a whole bunch of these questions,
and for companies like Microsoft
who sells products globally,
how do you parameterize
those things?
It's not as easy as changing
the language is in and out.
You're changing
moral codes in and out,
and how do you
represent that's in
your systems, your technology?
>> So, what I was
going to say that
I think relates to that point,
is that it's one thing
if one legal regime
has a standard here and
another one is just higher,
but it's a totally
different thing
if they actually conflict.
I think around discrimination,
there more potentially
in conflict.
So, the problems are
a little deeper than
just a higher floor.
>> I mean, just to build
on that a little bit.
So, Brad Smith published
a blog post calling for
government regulation of
face recognition
technology in July.
I want to sort of dig
into this and say,
"Is that the right approach,
and who should be
making decisions about
what makes a system
fair or ethically okay.
Is it the government?
Which government?
How do you reconcile
those differences?
Or is it companies like
Microsoft, or developers,
or perhaps the people
who are going
to be deploying these systems?"
>> So Deborah and I were talking
about this during lunch,
I think and in
some cases you have legal
president to set the floor,
and we come in and
say, you know what?
We don't think the floor is
acceptable enough and let's
go and notch higher
two notches higher.
Other instances like
facial recognition technologies,
there is no floor yet set
by the government and so,
we could go in and
say here's what we
think of potential Flores.
And Brad Smith posts what he
called on was legislation
to to be used in
this category because it's
such a critical piece
and not just
facial recognition but I
also think biometrics.
So, in that one maybe be
corporations who are
doing technology work in
this space work alongside with
regulators to define the space,
educate each other, and
sets a floor around
behavior there.
>> I would agree with
them. Just add one thing
that legal answers or
legal interventions are going
to be more cumbersome and
often after the fact and
laws often tend to be more.
They're not as targeted to
a specific problem that occurs.
So, I think even if you
have the law coming in
there's always going
to be a room for
companies to supplement that.
>> So, I guess I was
rather hoping an economist
would ask this question though,
what's wrong with just
letting the market fix it?
If your face recognition
software is bias then
people aren't going to
buy it and if you have
these accurate data sheets then,
they know what they're
getting and they can
just not buy something
that doesn't
do what they want it to do
and if they do buy it and
they release a product
that is bias then people
aren't going to buy the product
and the company will go-.
>> I think the issue
is like for me,
it's pretty crazy that it took
for Joy [inaudible] paper for
like Kamala Harris deciding when
she's writing to the FBI
and things like this.
People have been using
face recognition forever, right?
They've been using
in law enforcement,
companies have been using it.
So, even though it was bias
for a long time people
have been using it.
So for me I'm not an economist,
so, I don't know
much about markets.
But for me, this says the market
hasn't been fixing it.
Also, a lot of times I think that
when you have something that
unfairly punishes minorities,
it could be a minority of
people who don't
really have a voice,
I don't know if the market
helps these people, right?
I think this is
legislature in my opinion.
>> So, I mean, the point of
anti-discrimination law
is to protect groups that
don't have either the
political power or
the economic power to
protect themselves
in the marketplace,
which is why I'm
actually not worried
about the green
eyed eyeball thing
because I think actually
you would expect the market
to self-correct.
That the point of
anti-discrimination law
is to protect those groups that
historically haven't been able
either economically or politically
to protect themselves.
>> Question over there.
>> I keep on saying
minority and then Joy
always said that under
sampled majority,
I love that term, so
I'm going to correct
myself, under sample majority.
>> Which is a good
example of my point,
the data sheets
are a good step in
the right direction
but if somebody who
studies metadata and
information retrieval,
metadata itself is socially
constructed and has lots
of biases built-in.
So, what we really need here
is a governance process.
Who's going to watch the watchers
around metadata processes too.
So I'm going to add that
to fairness issues.
>> Great. Another
question over there.
>> It was actually
more of a comment,
I was mentioning to you before.
I'm Tina [inaudible] ,
for those of you who
don't know me I'm
a professor at
Northeastern University.
I think is not the job of
Machine Learning to fix
the biases that are
in the data because
our society is broken.
I think the job of
Machine Learning is to show that
the policies are
not being enforced
correctly and go back and
change those policies.
So as opposed to using
Machine Learning
to make human decisions,
we should use Machine Learning to
show that the data that's
coming out of the enforcements
of the policies are bad,
go to policymakers and have
the policies get changed
or the enforcement
of it get changed.
>> How would that work in
like let's say hiring?
So, I'm trying to
understand your comment.
So, when you have
an automated tool that is
then shown to break certain laws
that already exist like,
let's say Equal Employment
Opportunity Act or
something like that.
Then, don't you think
that the automated tool
itself should change
to not break that law?
>> So the question is that is
the algorithm doing
the wrong thing
or is the data that you're
getting from the enforcement
of the policy,
let's say stop-and-frisk, right?
So, there's a stop
and frisk policy,
I have cameras on cops,
it's taking data,
and if I can from that
data reconstruct
the intent of the policy,
and then say look.
Did you intend to
your policy to do
X to the policy maker?
Right? If the person says yes,
and that the intent is oh,
wait a second
stop-and-frisk is stopping
black and brown people
more than others.
What is your intent?
I bet most policymakers
will say no,
that was not my intent
of stop-and-frisk.
But the question is
how do you actually
change society not that, oh,
I have to come up with
the Machine Learning algorithm
because it's going to be used
in human decision-making
because we
have all this data
that's coming out.
Because a human
decision makers are using it
mostly for efficiency
purposes, right?
That's why they like
risk assessments,
which are very bad in
my perspective because they
don't give you any uncertainty
about the algorithm, right?
Eight, right?
So, Tina goes to jail.
>> I don't think we
would disagree that it's
a bad idea to use
data to point out
problems we have with our
policies but at the same time or
systems are being used already
today in the world which
is already biased.
So you have have to make
decisions and you can
say as a company,
well it's unfair
that the number of
applicants of minorities
and women for
computer companies is
unbalanced and that poses
all kinds of problems we have in
our educational system
and earlier on.
But we don't want to just
say let's wait until they
solve that and then
when we have 50,
50, we have to make
decisions today and
the algorithms have
to make decisions
in where we are right now.
>> So, I guess my answer
to that is that it's
not that we have to wait is
that it has to be in parallel.
>> Exactly.
>> Right? The other one is
that what are the incentives are
there decision makers that are
using your algorithms, right?
Because it wasn't like before,
they were using the data, right?
So obviously, we have
stupid algorithms,
like mandatory minimum
sentencing that
do not look at data, right?
But the question is,
you have to take into
account incentives
of the people who are
using your algorithms,
and I don't think people are
really looking into that.
>> So, I think all the cases
don't look like the
stop-and-frisk kind of case,
that there are
some cases where there
are injustices or
unfairness in the past
that I think those
of us who are in
this world carrying about
algorithms don't want to compound
those prior injustices and
that's an independent concerns.
So one example I like to use
is insurance companies who,
and this doesn't involve
any complicated AI
but it would charge
domestic abuse victims.
>> More for health
and life insurance
because if you're being beaten up
by your husband or boyfriend,
you are more likely to need
health or life insurance.
Now, the insurance company
wasn't the one that was
responsible for the women
being beaten up.
In fact, even after you
left your batterer,
you were most at risk.
So, they would charge them
higher rates even if they've
left their batterer.
But, I think the response
that most people have is,
there's something
unfair about that.
It's not an accurate reflection
of their actuarial risk and it's
not that the insurance
company is somehow
responsible for
perpetrating the violence
against these women,
yet still, you might think
they shouldn't compound
that injustice,
that an injustice had been done
to someone and there's something
morally troubling about carrying
that injustice into
another domain.
Now, not only the woman
got beaten up,
but now she can't get
health or life insurance.
So, I think there are a lot
of situations that raise
those kinds of questions
that I think are
important to think about.
>> I wanted to ask a question
back to the original idea
about fairness.
So, I have a lot of concern
about facial recognition ever
being used on balance
better or well,
for society than on balance
injuring as a society.
So, one of the things
that I'm thinking
a lot about is when does
a company or when does
a technologist that
develops a system say,
"This isn't going
to work in the way,
there's too much
unfairness and so,
I'm just cutting
bait, it's done."
I would like to know
what the metric,
if that's ever happened in
your experience and
what the metric is?
I'll just give you
an example in law,
there was a brief time
when the death penalty
was determined to be
not working the way we,
as a society, needed it to work.
So, we stopped in the United
States administering it.
We've now gone back
to it thinking
that it's now working better,
but there were metrics by
which that was being measured.
We could agree or disagree
about whether those are
the right metrics and
whether it's still working,
but I'd like to hear from
a technology perspective,
whether there is
an indication that it is
so unfair or the outcome is
so wrong that we can't fix it.
>> I, well.
>> It's a very good question.
I'm thinking a lot
about this right
now because, for example,
when our paper with
Joyce paper first came out,
what some people were saying was,
"So, why are you
trying to fix it?"
Because we know that
for African-Americans,
for example, it's
being used unfairly.
So, even if it works perfectly,
should we have this technology?
I have a lot of
thoughts about this,
but I think the two things
are separate, right?
Like, there's one thing where
you're showing disparity
in how something works and
then the second thing is,
what that thing is
being used for.
So, in one way,
the fact that we
showed disparity,
I think, helps people now
say we need to have legislation.
For example, in
California, right?
They said there was
legislation passed on
the senate floor to say that,
before law enforcement uses
face recognition technology,
we have to audit
it in California.
So, right now that's
not happening.
Everybody was just using face
recognition technology
the way they wanted it.
But at least showing
this disparity now starts to
have the conversation
where the public
and our elected officials
and everybody
else can actually at least make
a decision about whether we want
to use it in certain
use cases or not.
But, I don't support
a complete ban on face
recognition technology
under any circumstances
whatsoever.
I mean, I might change my mind
if I talked to other people
about this because,
there are some cases
in which, for example,
when Affectiva by that emotion to
recognition technology
was started,
Hanna talks about how she
was working with kids,
with autistic kids
and how this was
helping kids with autism.
People have written
about older people with
dementia and how some of
this technology might help.
So, I think we
have to look at it on
a case-by-case basis.
For certain applications,
like for example,
screening people at the airport.
There's too many false-positives,
I don't think it should be
used for that purpose, right?
Then, there maybe there's
other applications
for which you might still
want to use it for.
>> Eric.
>> It's a good question
you asked about, you know,
how do we make
these decisions and just in
terms of a couple of cases people
here might know about
the Aether Committee
at Microsoft and
advisory board that we
have Mira and Hanna,
serving on, the folks in
that board helped craft
the block that was
written on face recognition
and there was some recent cases
that have come to the board,
where Microsoft, the board
itself and then the
senior to Microsoft
said, "That's okay.
You know something? The scenario,
we're just not comfortable with,
we're not doing that contract."
There's a reason, a reasoning
that goes on, typically,
it's not metric-based or
accuracy-based in this case,
it's we don't understand
the usage well enough and
how it's going to
work in terms of
its implications
for human rights,
freedom of expression,
freedom of assembly,
how the errors are going
to work out in your life,
we have to study that further.
Sometimes, it doesn't
get down to accuracy,
it's like even even perfectly
accurate facial recognition,
perfectly fair bio-metric.
Let's say, one over
several people
on the panel might agree with,
even perfect recognition is that,
it can cause a chilling effect
when it comes to
freedom of expression
and freedom of assembly,
when using a public square.
So, it depends on
the usage and so on,
but I could just make a comment
here and it's okay because we're
going to be going out and we
are going to be
public about this,
I just whisper it to her,
"Is this being videoed?"
Because I was going to gauge
my level precision on this,
there are a couple of
topics in that place,
but we are going to be
going public about some of
these cases for feedback
without the names of the
various customers, for example.
But, we've actually had
deliberations on this committee
and working with Russell T.,
and we vaguely said no several
times and yes several
times and we try to
take those deliberations and
the answers will come up
with cross company
within divisions
as specifics that we try to
jam listen to principles to
make it easier the next
time around and then
keep on watching
the technology as it evolves.
I hope that help us with
if you give some examples.
>> So, I just want to build on
that a little bit and say
and ask a question about
how technology
companies should be
making those yes versus
no kind of decisions.
Should we be using some kind of
ethical framework to
guide these decisions,
some set of ethical principles
that we've decided on,
or should we be using
some other means?
>> So, I think it's
both of those plus,
I actually really like
what Microsoft has put
in place because there's
various levels of thinking
and checks and balances at
the corporate level that
Aether Board is looking
across the company at
scenarios and then generalizing
that into broad guidelines,
broad principles,
that you can then go
and take and apply
at the local level.
Then there are groups like mine,
there's actually
another group that's
similar in how they operate,
that go and do governance
at the local level and say,
"Okay, we have these principles.
Now, how do we apply
it at a local level?
How do we apply
these principles of fairness,
accountability,
transparency, privacy,
all of these on our technologies,
around face recognition,
speech recognition?"
So, this sort of two-tier model,
I think it's very
interesting because it lets
us scale and operate
at what corporate decisions
do we want to make
and what do we say yes and
no to and then locally,
how do we put things in
place around tooling,
around culture change
and educating
people around changing how
we do our design and development.
That's happening at a very
local level because it is very
specific to the culture
of the team,
the technology that
we're working on,
but having this sort
of laddering up,
I think is a very
interesting model to
explore because it lets you cover
very different audiences and
very different needs and
moves the company forward
in a positive way.
Because, if you just have
the corporate level,
what would happen is,
it would be PR speak,
it would just be
talk that was very
hard to translate
into how we apply it.
If you just have
the applied level,
you wouldn't have
the broad company orientation.
So, I think that
these two groups,
to me is a fascinating
experiment and
there's something
very good about that,
that I think other
companies can model.
>> Great. Well, with
that we're out of time.
Thank you everybody. Let's
thank our panelists.